the is that the noor or the lighting on
your face
this is a light i wish it was not i wish
it was not it's the life
um so man before we go in we got a
little bit of uh some comments
uh let's go through them and uh while we
do that tell us a little bit about your
story man a lot of people are wondering
this uh this handsome brother martial
that they got on the podcast i want to
know more about him so let's let's say
you want to give like a quick summary
about your life
i was born in kilburn northwest london
and then
shortly afterwards we moved to brighton
so
brighton is a predominantly white area
like by the sea
um and i was raised in a non-religious
uh household
so my mom was raised a christian
but it was more of a religion by name
my dad grew up in a jewish household but
he's always been a staunch atheist
so
we never really spoke about religion
whatsoever
um so it didn't really become a
a big issue for me or an important issue
until i got older um
so yeah
i won't mention too much about my life
in
school time and stuff like this but i do
feel that there's benefit uh
to you know acknowledging that my
character was very different back then
um
and
one important aspect that i'll mention
is
i grew up very quickly um matured at a
young age and i had a lot of
independence from early on
um so i think this gave me a lot of time
to think about life and things like this
and by the way if i'm working just stop
me but
you know um we'll carry on inshaallah so
as i got into my early teenage years and
this is when i got into involved in
you know the normal lifestyle of uh
clubbing drinking smoking stuff like
this
um and often it was leading to to
fighting or getting put in of a bad
predicament so
the first kind of turning point in my
life for me
was
one night i came home you know normal
clubbing drinking
and i must have had a few fights on on
this specific occasion
and i came home and i had broken
ligaments on my hands and i had blood on
my clothes and i was thinking to myself
there must be more to life than this
this can't be her and i was thinking you
know why am i here what's my purpose
what happens after i die
and all these sorts of questions
um and something interesting to note is
that i as a young child i do remember
you know distinctly having thoughts
about the creator like having conviction
that a higher being existed
um because anytime i wanted something or
needed something i'd always ask the
creator
to provide
um
but because of these
the questions i had questions i had
anyway i started to watch debates
and discussions surrounding these topics
um and at this point although i had
conviction that a higher being existed
i was convinced that
religions were man-made constructs used
by the minority to control the majority
and i still believe this
with regards to a lot of religions
to this day
so
some of the main arguments that
strengthened my conviction in the
creator at this time were
firstly the contingency argument
and secondly the fine-tuning argument so
yeah roberts do you want to give a
little input onto those
one thing i just want to say before rami
jumps in
and you were saying you were younging
and you just you just always had that
conviction bro
all i could say is fitrah bro there's
nothing else to say bro you don't need
dawah you don't need and i'm talking
about like the early primitive stages
you know you don't need every you know
you don't need to be born in the perfect
family you know that fitra is always
there bro that's so true well life's
very true
uh uh going on the contingency argument
i mean
it's basically just an argument for god
that um
anything that comes from another thing
you can't have an infinite chain of that
you can't have everything comes from
something else there must be something
that always existed that's it in a
nutshell
and this is a very powerful argument i
think i brought you know myself and many
other people
even if we believed in god just
strengthened that iman and again amen is
like
rational conviction it's not faith it's
not i just believe iman is like i i'm
convicted based off rationality
you know it's not a lot it does kind of
bring you to that state 100
so uh yeah you're at that point where
you got that uh that little argument
presented to you and masha'allah it
strengthened your email yeah where'd it
go from there
so
so yeah so the main belief that a
creator existed like it was uh okay for
me for a while like it was sufficient
but then i began to question more and
more about my purpose why i was here
and i began to to ask this creator this
this higher power
for guidance and
shortly after this
i bumped into an old school friend that
i hadn't seen for a long time
um and it was very random like we didn't
arrange to me or anything but when we
met up we we talked and we did we
arranged to meet up
again um and at this point we began to
discuss these topics and it would go on
for hours non-stop you know me asking
him questions him replying
um and he'd mentioned islam to me and he
mentioned islam
um and at this point i'd been told about
islam before by other people
but
they weren't had to sing the religion
themselves so i never took them
seriously this was my outlook back then
like if you're not practicing the
religion yourself
then why am i gonna listen to what
you've got to say you know
um
so there were yeah there were a few
things that that stuck out to me about
about this friend like a few of his
characteristics and how he was such as
he was very principled he had a lot of
discipline as well and this was
something that i really valued before
islam
um
and i think this was one of the reasons
that i did take him seriously and i did
listen to him
so uh
yeah and then just other things like he
was kind he lowered his gaze to the
opposite gender which was something very
different to me as well i'd never seen
this before um and obviously he prayed
five times a day he fasted in ramadan
and
all these things like this so
yeah although this was uh
[Music]
this stuck out to me a lot and it was
very profound to me um
i still wanted to shrug it off and i
wanted to have my own relationship with
god that didn't involve
me being dictated to or me being told
how to live my life me you know i wanted
to still follow my desires in that sense
um
kind of in the same manner as deism like
they believe in in the higher power but
they believe that higher power has no
uh control over their life or doesn't
want anything from them doesn't care
about how they treat others
um and stuff like this but something
within me just wouldn't accept this and
it didn't fit right with me
um
so looking back i wasn't a nice person i
wasn't kind to my parents
um i didn't have a sense of sympathy or
empathy for others and
weirdly during this period of time when
i did begin to question my purpose and
my existence
um i began to feel a sense of guilt
when i did certain things
and i i felt that i'd be held
accountable for these things
um even if people weren't there i knew
that the higher power was was witnessing
this
so yeah in my own time i began to
research more and more and
i thought to myself if this creator or
higher power exists then there must be a
reason behind our our creation
so a few weeks passed and my friend and
i met up again
and as we were driving back in his car
he says i've got something for you
and i say what is it
and then he gives me a translation of
the quran
and at this point i was making up so
many excuses about why i don't want this
no i'll just download the app on my
phone or
i don't need to read this um you know
but he ended up convincing me and i
ended up taking it
and it sat in my drawer in my room for a
while
until finally i opened up maybe probably
you know a few weeks later
and the first thing i noticed was was
the english was extremely old and it was
a hard read it was a hard read for me
because i wasn't really used to reading
books at this point
however it did make me ponder and it
wasn't like any other normal book that
i'd read before
uh you know it had it spoke of things
that i'd never even heard of before such
as
uh the day of judgement or jinn or
angels heaven and hell stuff like this
um so yeah it was very profound so i i
continued my research uh reading about
different religions watching uh academic
debates speakers calling the discussion
speakers corner played a huge role a
huge role for me
um and the common theme that struck me
was that i'd never seen
a muslim struggle to defend their
position
whilst all other
interlocutors or other
apologists would
be challenged on their positions by
muslims and failed to uphold them
so
i did more research into different
religions and i started to notice
problems within them for example
a religion that claims its holy book is
from the creator yeah it has
contradictions
historical errors multiple versions
or for example a religion that requires
you to be born into a certain lineage
for you to be eligible to follow it
or
a religion that requires the worship of
multiple all-powerful beings which is
obviously an an impossibility a logical
impossibility so
i got to the conclusion that the only
religion that was rational and coherent
was islam
so
when it came to islam
every single answer you could require
was there and not a stone was left
unturned
you know the quran had been preserved
for over 1 400 years
since the time it was first revealed
with no errors no contradictions
prophecies of the future
scientific discoveries unknown facts
about history and and and so much more
um so during this period of time i met i
was my friend again and this time we
were joined by our old school friends
and we hadn't seen them in a while
either
so we began discussing the topic of
islam
and my friends mentioned to me the
prophecies of the prophet muhammad peace
be upon him
and these prophecies blew my mind these
were amazing to me
like i'd never heard anything like this
before like how could a man 1 400 years
ago
predict things that have only just
started happening now in recent history
um
and this led to me defending islam even
though i had no affiliation to it like i
would be defending islam even though i
wasn't muslim at this point
um so yeah this this day really
triggered my
research into the prophet muhammad peace
be upon them
um and i found youtube discussions and i
found
articles and things like this
and i found
a
claim using deductive reasoning which
was
presenting free options
and it challenged people to bring
forth another option if there was one
possible and it said either this man
peace be upon him was lying about his
claim he was deluded or he was telling
the truth and if he wasn't lying and he
wasn't deluded then logic dictates that
he was telling the truth
um
so as for him being a liar
he was known his whole life
for his whole life up until delivering
the message as the truthful one
um
and if he was lying he would need a
motive so
he was offered power he was offered
money he was offered anything he could
want and he refused to give up this
message
when faced even when faced with severe
persecution and
the companions being tortured
as for him being deluded a deluded man
cannot conjure prophecies of the future
scientific discoveries unknown
historical facts or
recite eloquent uh recitations with over
40 rhetorical devices used in
three second three sentences you know
so he was telling the truth and anyone
who adopts the same consistency as they
do when it comes to
uh other non-religious matters they'll
also accept this
so soon after this my friend asked me to
come to friday prayer so uh dramaai
and i agreed
although i was very hesitant at the time
um
so it was the first time i'd been to a
mosque in my life um
but one of the first things i noticed
when i walked in
when i walked in was that there were you
know every single ethnicity was there
like every single different type of of
person was there
and at this point i had the opinion that
this religion was only for arabs so
this was something strange to me as well
so at this point i'd already been
intellectually convinced that islam was
the truth
and now i'd felt the spirituality aspect
for the first time
and i remember reasoning obviously
recently i remember reading something by
allah
and he mentioned that true conviction is
is not just intellectually so there has
to be a spiritual action
aspect as well
to back this up
so that was something very profound to
me as well
so anyway after that that friday
around a week later
i was working and i got invited to go to
one of the brothers houses to eat during
ramadan so obviously they'd been fasting
all day they were very hungry and
and stuff like that and
even
even though they were so hungry i was
offered food straight away you know all
these probably that brothers that i'd
never met before
greeting me asking how i am how's family
how's this how's uni how's it you know
and it was very strange because i'd
never seen this before in my life like
how i grew up if you don't know someone
then you you don't really care about
them you don't ask how they are how
their family are like stuff like this
so it was very uh
strange to me but very nice at the same
time
um and i also noticed again like
all these brothers
they were united under one common thing
and that was islam like even if they had
nothing else in common they had islam
and that's what brought them together
so
the same evening after we ate
we went to the mosque for tarawih
and we prayed for about two hours
straight bear in mind i was non-muslim
at this point but i was still standing
in prayer for for two hours straight and
i remember standing there and i was
thinking about like every single single
situation that i'd been in in my life um
and thinking about my conviction in
islam
and i was thinking about the reasons
that was stopping me from accepting
islam because i was completely convinced
that islam was the truth at this point
and the only thing stopping me was other
people's perceptions of me that's what i
came to the conclusion of
and at this point i fought back to a
conversation that i had with my friends
when we were sitting sitting in his car
and he told me we're gonna die
you know very simple statement he said
we are going to die
and
i remember in prayer i was thinking to
myself
that every single person that is alive
right now are gonna be dead in a hundred
years every single person is going to be
dead
and on my deathbed the last thing i'm
gonna care about is what other people
think of me
so there's no reason for me not to
accept islam so after prayer finished
we're about to leave the mosque and my
friend comes up to me just you know
about to leave like about to say okay
let's get in the car let's drive back
and i said two words them
i said i'm ready
and he was like ready for he thought i
was joking he's ready for he was
confused i said i'm ready to accept
islam
and he laughed he was like what do you
mean you're ready to say to sir
and i said no i'm serious i'm ready to
accept islam and he said to come to the
front so we went to the front of the the
mosque in front of a lot of people
because this ramadan is busy like 40 30
40 people at least
so he went to the front
and he said repeat after me
and i repeated the words after him
obviously i couldn't pronounce anything
so
he said repeat after me in english and i
said he said i bear witness that there
is no one worthy of worship except allah
and i bear witness that muhammad is his
messenger and i repeated after him
uh so i was 19 at the time and it's now
been around two and a half years and
that's my story
[Music]
mashallah habibi it's only been two and
a half years
because i dare say that was one of the
best reverb stories that i've heard
beautiful it's very smooth
it seems like obviously everyone has
their bumps but you know
rational conviction logical conviction
you're intellectually there you go to
the masjid you're spiritually there and
then it's like
this is this is
it is very heartwarming
my first question is are you still close
with the brothers today
i'm still very much close to the
brothers
do you think you would have accepted
islam without seeing that brotherhood
that connection
i don't think so i mean this friend was
a you know a huge huge component to me
except in islam um
like
yeah like once you see the brotherhood
this is
this is a really big uh
indicator of the truth of islam because
nothing unites people like this you know
yeah one hundred percent in the there
are ayat in the quran
specifically tells us either to stay
together or not to depart from each
other
actually gives us a way to resolve
conflicts
uh he says uh
i forget the ayah specifically but he
basically says if two groups of muslims
are fighting
then stop the one that's oppressing
until they come basically back to the
path of allah and it's it's very
beautiful
made it very very clear for us that we
have to unite as brothers to stay very
close and the reason i asked that is
because of those ayats so alhamdulillah
is very beautiful to hear that because
there are three words unfortunately
that they don't have that and because
they don't have that they end up leaping
i honestly genuinely believe that that's
the one thing that if people have they
will stay in the stem and if they don't
they'll be heavily heavily pushed to
leave because no amount of logical
rational conviction can really hold
people unless they have that that social
aspect that emotional bonding
uh which is very
it's very true very very true like the
first
the first year or even two years you're
very um vulnerable in a sense
because the people around you are are
going to invent
influence you heavily
um and if you don't have that islamic
you know the fundamental education at
the beginning
you can go pretty off track so i'm doing
that
something like that
so sorry for that bro take it away
man you had something on your mind you
see me taking i'm cold
we've had storms in in the uk so
you are you still in brighton right now
yes yes yes what's the what's the
weather i bro
man it's crazy like it's storm
everything's been blowing away trees are
falling down
a brother in the uk just sent me a video
on tick tock and he was talking about
the end times he said that um
basically
they don't get that kind of weather in
the uk that you don't get these kind of
natural disaster type
events you know hurricanes and all that
stuff and he mentioned that there's been
a warning that hurricane's going to the
uk
and he's like this is the sign of the
end times and he showed a wall he's like
this wall has been standing up forever
and it's just a bunch of bricks like
laying on the floor because it's been
completely tough
it's kind of love so
[Music]
one thing on my mind right now
that you said i really want to know this
and i think this might benefit viewers
that are riverts
uh non-muslims or just born muslims or
just no matter where they are bro
you mentioned al-khazali talked about
the benefits of balancing spirituality
and and that intellectual conviction
right
yeah for someone like yourself i want to
know your firsthand anecdotal experience
what really helped you get that
spirituality because
intellectuality can come or you know
being intellectually convicted can come
from anything bro it can come from
youtube videos it can come from taking a
course it can come from reading books
but no matter how learned one is
they might not have that spiritual side
so what really was a pivotal role in
helping you and like you can give me
more than one thing
that's an amazing question masha allah
so i think the main thing for me was
that
allah
you know the higher power always
answered my my prayers like even before
islam
for example when i was asking for
guidance what happened i bumped into my
friend and we we start discussing islam
or when i'm
asking for guidance and i'm coming
across
uh
reading material or
videos and and things like this so i
think first-hand experience of
uh
your prayers being answered is a very
very uh big aspect of spirituality for
me
so yeah
do you remember what was on your mind
uh well firstly i want to pull up this
this comment from the sister um
who mentioned the quran so
surah 49 verse 9 allah says this is a
translation but still paraphrasing allah
says if two groups of the believers
fight each other seek great
reconciliation between them and if one
of them commits aggression or oppression
against the other fight that uh fight
the one that commits oppression of allah
so it's very clear it's very
beautiful
you know that allah even gives us a
formula to stop fighting but you know
allah it's beautiful i'm trying to
remember what i what i was gonna say
before
it was a question but um regardless
let's move on
what other roadblocks do you think that
you had
on the reverse story and after you were
any roadblocks
okay so before islam
i i don't think it was anything else
than people's perceptions of me because
you know my family
although they may not be happy with me i
knew they would not disown me kick me
out of the house or anything like this
him do less so i think mainly it would
be people's perceptions of me when i
accept islam
and maybe the relationships i'd have to
cut off once i did accept islam
um
and the friendship you know
or
things that would not be normal to me
such as going out drinking clubbing
uh
you know partying i'd have to cut these
off so probably these would be the
hardest things for me
and as for now alhamdulillah i don't
think i have any which is a big big
blessing so
so how about after the reversion in the
last two and a half years were there any
roadblocks or what were some of the more
you know monumental moments the the ups
in the last two and a half years as well
to be honest everything's been up well
everything everything's been up um
you know we all go through hard
hardships but
when you have islam you have you know
you have something that keeps you
grounded you have something that gives
you
reason for every single thing that
happens to you
you know no matter how small it is if
you drop your water bottle as you're
walking outside you know there's a
reason for this no matter how small the
thing is and you know the biggest
calamities that happen to you these are
for a reason also and you know that
everything that happens to you you're
going to be rewarded for it in the
hereafter
so this is something
you know uh amazing this is an amazing
thing from the religion
bro i gotta ask you this
do you think
and and you know what no i'll just ask
you bro
if you feel comfortable obviously do you
do you want to tell us where your
relationship is now with
everyone like i'm assuming you know your
family
they all know you know maybe they they
and you told me you know they're they're
definitely
uh it's progressive right but how did
that go bro how did you tell them or the
rest of your family or friends that you
were at the time i know you said that
you know it was something that was uh a
hurdle for you to overcome you know
caring what other people think the
external reinforcement validation so how
did you overcome that what did you do
uh so as for the first point
um
in regards to friends and family now
well and how they found out so
unlike other
reverse or converse i actually told my
family straight away so
i think
either the same day or the the morning
after maybe so
i accept islam in the in the mosque for
terrorist right after the prayer
and i think by the morning i told my dad
already
so
i remember i walked in and i said that
i've got something to tell you
um
and i've never seen someone so scared in
my life i'm sure my dad's watching this
right now or i'll send it to him soon
inshallah but yeah he's
his face dropped like his face uh
physically dropped and he said i don't
think he even spoke his face dropped so
i think the media plays a big big role
in this um and i can't blame him for how
he felt and stuff like that but yeah um
it was fine like he
although he wasn't happy he accepted it
um
i didn't get kicked out of the house i
was still allowed to live there and as
for my mom because they lived separately
um
so my mom
you know my life she's she's always
happy with with my decisions so
you know she was very happy for me
and friends as well they were happy as
well you know
um obviously it meant that i couldn't do
the same things i would normally do with
them
i'd have to distance myself a little bit
but you know i've i've got very good
relationships with
my non-muslim friends up until now and
insha'allah the relationships will stay
stay like this as well
inshallah so when you said you got to
distance yourself
you already know what we're talking
about anyone watching this
it's a daily fit now bro
you know uh not being overly judgy
towards people but just saying you know
what i can't hang out with you you know
if you didn't do this i can't partake in
this if you're gonna go there i can't do
it you know and and i get it bro it's
it's tough bro so definitely but here's
the thing this is the beauty of it we
all have that choice
and may allah keep us among the ones
that see it as an easy choice bro i mean
and not something like oh man i can't do
this i can't do that you know
yeah
i mean and you know subhanallah a lot of
the time if you look a lot of the time
when you put things in a non-religious
perspective people don't have an issue
with it it's like oh you know these
group of friends they um
they go drinking and i can't drink
because if i drink you know it's gonna
kill me one day uh everyone's gonna tell
you like if they're not gonna give it up
for you if they're not if they're gonna
keep inviting you stay away from them
and everyone's gonna praise that person
if someone has people holding them back
from their dreams in a very liberal way
um
you know i want to go for my dreams and
blah blah they're going to tell them
drop your friends but as soon as we say
that you know i'm going to drop these
people because they don't align with my
beliefs as a muslim
all of a sudden like you know people
lose their mind so i think that kind of
perspective is really important to have
it'll you know i think it'll give people
a sense of strength as well in leaving
these people behind because at the end
of the day
uh if it's you or them you have to pick
yourself for sure for sure and you know
one amazing thing one very you know
important aspect is that something that
attracted
me to islam
was the behavior of of my friend his
principles his discipline
so
if if you're muslim and you're you don't
want to upset non-muslims by not
partaking in certain things
you need to think to yourself like this
person is going to respect you a lot
more for standing by your principles
than just
you know falling for anything they want
you to do
[Music]
that's very great 100 100
and omar man he writes the more you come
close to allah the greater the trial it
reminds me of uh allah saying that you
know do do they think they're gonna say
i believe in and you know they won't be
tested so
honestly man i feel like before islam
there's a fitnah after islam there's a
fitnah and this this dunya is is prison
bro for the believer yeah and paradise
for those
uh you know that are disbelievers and
just make their their nafs their rub bro
and that's at the end of the day that's
that's all we could do is just be
patient and just have somebody and just
have to wake up that everything we're
doing allah is gonna you know reward us
for that and may allah keep us firm in
that too because there's a lot of people
just blindly believing that you know but
there's another level of iman that you
genuinely understand okay cool i'm
turning this down into dunya but it
doesn't matter it doesn't mean anything
anyway all this money all this fame all
these opportunities if they're not going
to bring me closer to allah they really
don't matter
exactly and nothing you know nothing
that
islam tells us not to do
everything that islam tells us not to do
is for a reason allah has chosen this
for a reason
and
we can see the the benefits in our in
our in our life in our lives right now
like
we can see the benefits of not drinking
alcohol not smoking no
you know xena
gambling all of these things they have
so many many uh harms that come from
them like
you know
they're destroyers of society
like these things
okay people may say in moderation but
who's to determine the criteria for what
moderation is and what moderation isn't
you know
we had a we had a brother by the name of
zahabi on the podcast yes and i'm sure
you know i love that
i love i love that brother for the sake
of a love bro and when we when we had a
mon bro subhanallah like
insha allah the viewers got as much
benefit as we did because people don't
know how much benefit that we get you
know compared to just all the viewers so
i can only imagine but
i myself i gain tremendous value from
just even being here you know as a host
but if it was brother farah said one
thing
he said that
you know
bro i don't know why but i just went
blank bro i pulled it on her i literally
had that thought bro in my head and it
just went away but i'll bring it up if i
if i do remember
no problem
did you have something to say
you understand
no i mean
you're welcome to ask me a question i've
actually got questions for you brothers
in charlotte
prepare a few things all right
and to any of the viewers that made it
this far if you're wondering where angel
is
the brother has kovid you know
and may allah grant himself a and make
it easy for him and
inshallah grant him to be back on the
podcast asap you know so please make
some dua for him and inshaallah you will
see him on monday if not then inshallah
definitely by friday
okay question time
go for it bro so
you know i think whether we're born into
islam or whether we accept islam at a
later age
i think i and i believe we all have that
one point where
we acknowledge that islam is the truth
so i'm interested to know when that was
for you
rami bro why don't you go first
all right bismillah so you know
i think there's there's a fair amount of
similarities between your story and my
story brother sam although i was born
into family alhamdulillah i was and i
was brought up upon it i wasn't very
practicing and i didn't have that
a proper akita established the proper
belief established
uh but you know subhanallah one day and
keep in mind i went to a catholic school
so that's the kind of education i was
getting i was reading
some parts of the bible in religious and
religion class and all that stuff and
talking about their beliefs about you
know all that stuff so
i
i was on youtube one day and i don't
know why because i didn't really watch
islamic stuff at all but on my explore
page on youtube
i remember seeing a video that
it just intrigued me it said you know
how satan came to be or the creation of
satan or something like that and i was
like okay
you know that's interesting i know that
in in christianity they believe it's a
fallen angel
and um okay that's interesting so i went
and i watched it and the way they spoke
and everything they spoke about and
everything
referencing the quran
it was just not really what i imagined
it to be so like you know what that's
very interesting it's amazing they also
talked about you know there could be
creations outside that we don't know
about and kind of like referring to them
as like aliens it could be aliens and
that stuff i thought that was
interesting so i i kept going
and i got to the speaker corner videos
as well it got to the muhammad hijab and
ali daba and all that stuff and
uh and i think this was around the time
like ali dao was going toe-to-toe with
like tommy robinson and
jada whatever her name is islamophobic
uh you know older white lady and all
these people i'm like you know
subhanallah this this is amazing and
then i got to the david wood videos and
i got to like those videos i'm like oh
this is not so amazing i'm like well
what's going on here man what's this and
then
i got the responses from the muslims
towards those people i'm like wow they
just like like swept the floor at them
like they blew them not just out of the
water they blew them out of the ocean
and they're like like they're done
back from those responses so i'm like
you know this is amazing this is the
truth and then i kept learning and
practicing i started debating people on
my my catholic school as well i still
remember very vivid memories bro of like
debating people on the bus on the way to
our field trip downtown and it was fun i
really enjoyed alhamdulillah but that's
that's what brought me to them
alhamdulillah by the way
brothers i remembered what i was going
to say about ferrazabi so pertaining to
your thing about alcohol and where do
you draw the line that's that's one
thing bro that in and of itself that
idea that i know when to stop or i can
distinguish left and right sometimes you
know when it gets blurry and i know what
is too much we don't and
was saying every single thing more or
less that's haram destroys the family if
you really think about it bro
now when it comes to me all right i'm
not gonna you know allah puts a blanket
over our sins so we shouldn't
unnecessarily you know just expose them
for the sake of so you know and there's
there's times when it's wise you know to
prove a point but for this one i'm gonna
you know sit out but what i will say is
i was doing stuff that i shouldn't have
been doing obviously you know and a lot
of people like what do you mean
shouldn't biola you know based on the
standards that allah has set forth i was
doing stuff that i shouldn't be doing
and it was destroying me right mentally
physically it was really destroying me
and
i let it get too far
all right
and when i was too far i wasn't too
practicing i wasn't praying i wasn't you
know
and i remember i made
one dua to allah all right in that state
bro in that state where i was just not
physically mentally on ten and i was
like ya allah if you're listening
um help me feel normal help me feel
steady help me feel just just give me my
life back just help me feel a glimpse of
hope
and i'm never going to be doing what i
was doing you know
and i made the house very sincere and as
a man it was it was as if i made like a
promise or a pact with allah a covenant
you know i was just like
you know if you could just help me
please allah i'll never do you know any
of these things again and i'll never be
you know repeating these mistakes and so
on and so forth so because of that you
know truth be told and i know it sounds
like a fairy tale bro but subhanallah
instantly i felt this rush of iman and
just normalcy and stability
and i kid you not it's that
in that moment that state just getting
that delivery from allah bear in mind
allah doesn't almost anything bro so the
fact that allah gave me that instantly
um
almost the fear of
should i try to test allah again should
i try to you know go back to that and
see what happens and
what if it gets worse and how would i be
you know if on the day of judgment allah
says and allah tells me you know when
you cried for help when you repented and
you and you wanted to go back on your on
you know
and i helped you you went back to the
fire you know and i i would be left bro
i wouldn't know what to say because at
that point it generally would have been
on me you know
so
it just kept me on dean bro and since
then alhamdulillah was just an uphill
thing
i left all those things you know i met
brothers like rami that genuinely had a
marvelous impact on my life so may allah
bless me and all the other brothers and
sisters i mean for all the work they do
and
alhamdulillah bro looking back at it
it's crazy because
i was really reflecting as rami was
giving you his answer you know because
when he first asked what was your
defining moment i was like bro for me it
was probably progressive you know it
wasn't like one thing yes if i really
think about it that was generally the
cornerstone bro
i have a question for you before we go
on all right so
before islam me
and angel right i can't speak on rami
because you know i specifically spoke
about this to on hell one day but i'm
pretty sure that ami can agree um a lot
of men they find being humble as being
weak right and
pre-deen right for us
uh or at least for me and pre-islam for
anha right we thought that you know
being humble was a weakness but after
islam after immersing ourself
and and doing our best to fully submit
to allah
bro humility is just something natural
to the fitra
and just being kind just being genuine
no thought in my mind comes across that
it's weakness or anything
have you had a similar experience to
that
i definitely think so um
even now after islam like
no longer am i worried about uh did i
say the wrong thing to this person
is this person gonna come and try
something now because i
behaved in this manner or
did i say yeah you know like
do i have a problem with this person not
alhamdulillah i can sleep now knowing
you know i've done my best not to
uh
anger anyone i've tried to be kind to
people and
this is a very uh
calming for it's very calming because
you don't you don't need to worry about
anything you do look if you follow what
allah has has set for you as guidelines
then this is protection in it in and of
itself you know
so yeah
okay allah about a freak bro now to
anyone watching that made it this far we
got 15-inch minutes left on the stream
ask any of your questions that you want
brother sam to answer and inshallah
we'll facilitate that
um aside from that bro tell us about
learning arabic bro your tajweed
mashallah is is definitely on par with
some you know
imams at the massages bro and i'm not
just saying that you know just to you
know
boast you or anything like that but
genuinely mashallah it's it's definitely
something that's not you know i don't
see too often in a lot of reverts two or
three years in so what steps have you
taken to genuinely you know step up your
arabic game firstly may allah bless you
but it's really not this level i promise
i will insha allah one day but
alhamdulillah so
firstly the brother that that
played a huge role in epson islam
not only did he play that role but
he's stayed with me throughout the whole
journey and he's taught me
you know how to read quran how to recite
properly he he still teaches me tajweed
up until this day so without him
i would not be in the position i mean
not even close and on top of this of
course i do my own studies like
uh i have a teacher online and and i try
to
practice in my own time so alhamdulillah
like
you know allah just has made everything
very easy for me
like really facilitated
do you have any questions or uh
do you want me to go in on boxing
all right man sam
tell us about boxing man and just in
general just
fitness martial arts because i'm into
that and and rami's into the on hills
into that we're all advocates of that
and a lot of viewers wondering they're
here like okay yo i get it bro fitness
fitness fitness but the akkid is the
only thing that matters dunya it doesn't
really matter we shouldn't you know as
long as you have your dean it doesn't
matter how you look what are your
thoughts on on just really working on
yourself in terms of
athleticism functionality fitness
why do you do it and you know where are
you at
cool so i think there's a lot to unpack
here but
the main points i would like you know to
focus on is that fitness is not just
some
side aspect of islam fitness is is a
huge huge part of islam like
uh
religious you'd think of them you may
think of them as someone who
studies all the time
prays all the time fast all the time but
if that person isn't looking after the
body that allah has loaned to them
because remember we don't own this this
is what allah has given us for a
temporary period of time
and we need to look after it the way it
should be looked after
using the guidelines that allah has set
for us
so fitness is a huge aspect of islam and
strengthening the body having good
nutrition these will play
fundamental roles not just physically
but for mental
health as well
training is is is integral and training
you know
like physically mentally but spiritually
also
you know when you're eating good food
and
you're you're fit you're healthy you can
do more alberta you can
you can be more productive you can spend
more time with
quaran because you have the right fuel
in your body you have the right energy
in your body so there's so many aspects
to unpacked but uh to unpack
but
it's not something to be uh played down
like fitness is a huge huge a huge
aspect of islam now obviously we do need
to find the balance because
we don't want to just go to the gym and
and get big for
to look good like oh the muslims should
definitely look good and be presentable
but when it starts going to the ego side
of things then it becomes a bit of a
problem
and yeah this is a challenge that i'm
sure all of us face in the fitness
community because
uh you know we're trying to build our
platforms and and and sometimes this
this
you it's a it's a constant uh battle of
your your with your knee like you need
to have your intention correct
um so those are you know
some the main points that i would i
would uh bring up inshallah what do you
guys think i mean you know how you were
recalling all those all those people
that were on deen and until you met
muslims that generally put their money
where their mouth was you know they they
walked the walk not just talk to talk
you couldn't really take the the dean
seriously right so think about it like
this you see someone that's out of shape
and i know today you know there's all
this propaganda on body shaming and all
this nonsense but bear in mind all right
you see someone that's out of shape okay
i get it you know people are gonna be
like what if they have a metabolic
disease what if all this what about is a
messiah right the general population
that has an obesity problem it's usually
indicative of a lack of self-control and
discipline and self-respect right and
all of these things are things that we
believe it or not we judge people by and
usually if you want to give da'awa or
you want to propagate the dean or you
have any type of motive that you have
whether it's dunya or
people are more likely to just believe
you and respect you and and and see that
transparency
if they know you take yourself seriously
because how are they going to take you
seriously if you don't take yourself
seriously
very good point very very good fight
yeah
me bro what about you
i honestly don't have much to add i
think the points you made my shot kind
of covered it all that's enough you know
for for people to to to get the point
that they need to take care of the you
know the the vessel allah has filled
their soul with
allah
how much time do you guys have today
as much as you want inshallah well you
know
sorry sorry say that one more time
i just said it's late in the uk but
you've got all my time inshallah don't
worry it's definitely late rami what
about you i actually have to get going
uh because uh tiff's here tonight
okay okay
so you mean like you're done now right
okay in that case
it was a pleasure i'm gonna stay with
the brother we'll do a quick q a but uh
in terms of ramy man
for uh all the benefit you brought today
and always around me
and uh look forward to seeing you on
monday
the sake of allah
all right bro
so sam
while i go to the youtube uh you know
comment section live chat change it from
members only to anyone why don't you
answer this question inshallah
oh
um
i don't think i can say you know because
i haven't read any of them fully
um so yeah i'm gonna have to skip this
one inshaallah i've never read all of
them fully
okay alhamdulillah it should be open to
subscribers only now instead of members
so anyone have your questions let's go
um let's see
this 1am in the uk i think definitely
man it's super late
um
let's see
where's uh insert clickbait so you said
you had a question if you don't mind uh
letting us know the question
there we go are you boxing
professionally and if so what weight
class do you compete in
okay so
uh the title is a bit misleading because
i'm not a boxer myself i'm a boxing
coach
um i'm a boxing coach but i love boxing
uh the training aspect of boxing
so yeah alhamdulillah all right next
will you both come to malaysia
i would love to come to malaysia and
shout allah if that's the invite
a close friend of ours brother gabriel
romani he lives in malaysia so would
definitely like to go
alaikum salaam to everyone
okay next
who's your favorite boxer of all time
muhammad ali
all the time okay what about right now
like recently oh uh
i'm a tyson fury fan to be honest all
right all right you guys heard it first
nabeel
how can we stop overthinking when
playing a sport
maybe like performance anxiety in the
likes
um
i think probably just have your goals
clear
um no know what you need to do in your
sport it's quite a vague question so i'm
not really sure how to answer that too
well but just know
you know have have your objectives in
mind
okay so even though you are not a
professional boxer you just love boxing
how has impact how has islam impacted it
so for example if someone would have
asked me that for fitness i would say
okay i just don't wear shorts that show
my aura you know like just for example
what are things that you could come up
with
yeah so things like this
one thing i'm i'm very
adamant on is not using music in my
videos so for example
when i'm filming
my boxing
you know shadow boxing or
coaching clients i won't use any music
in my videos and i think this is
something like you don't need to
to
sacrifice on your principles just to get
a few more extra views and things like
this so i think that's quite a
beneficial point to mention in sha allah
i love that song i love that because
people are thinking logically bro but
how are we going to use logic to dictate
allah bro allahu subhan transcends logic
bro logic is something we created bro
because think about it logically why
should we turn down a job that's going
to make us more money
given that it's haram you know logically
why should we not listen to music and
put music on our on our videos if it
gets us more views logically right but
they don't realize bro that
logic plays no role here it's turning
these things down for the sake of allah
whether it be putting music to get more
views whether it be making i don't know
putting women in your thumbnails to get
more views
or taking on a job that has a lot of
money bro but it's hard it's turning
these things down
that will give you the barakah from
allah it's not doing these things and
getting a punishment and getting a sin
and
potentially getting punished bro it's
not worth it you know
and also
acknowledging that the laws of allah are
you know they're firm in place just like
the laws of gravity
there's certain things that will have
certain consequences um so you do yeah
as the brother said you really don't
need to compromise uh compromise your
deen
100 100 percent
it's got a lot of
money to accept our goal
i mean i mean i mean
okay
next question let's see
welcome brother may allah bless you and
keep you from do you think i can get
into boxing at 24 years old
any age insha'allah allah any age
insha'allah
any asian charlotte it's never too late
never too late
abdullah have your parents seen a
positive change in your life
this is one of my brothers
i'd have to ask them but i'd hope so i
definitely hope so
well just just for uh
yeah i mean look when you when you used
to come back from clubs at 4am
drunk and then you're coming back from
the masjid at 4am i'm sure
there's uh
they would prefer the second
definitely definitely definitely
all right besides boxing do you have
interest in any other kind of
self-defense sport such as taekwondo
karate etc
so me personally i've never actually
tried anything else i've tried muay thai
one time
but i'm you know it wasn't for me
bro bro listen if i tried muay thai too
i'm not gonna speak for the choir but me
personally it wasn't for me when i got
into jiu jitsu bro it just stuck with me
so i really recommend trying it out bro
this is you know jiu jitsu is something
i really really want to try i really
want to try definitely and and before i
give the next question you're doing
boxing bro i did a little bit of boxing
and i noticed that it's very similar to
muay thai in the sense it's like speed
and footwork and all that but when you
when you really do jiu jitsu there's a
lot of strategy involved bro it's
mentally like exhausting bro like when i
do muay thai i don't know if this is
just me but i physically feel exhausted
and mentally i feel released relieved
you know but when i do jujutsu
i feel mentally exhausted too bro like
it takes a on another level of just you
know rewiring your brain and strategy
bro
definitely no definitely
all right it's a general question i have
heard doing professional unboxing and um
i think because the face gets harmed so
we made a lot of videos on this and
we're not you know scholars so we're not
going to give any futaba here
um
no comment yeah
question who's winning the han vs brook
fight tomorrow
oh
i wouldn't consume him i wouldn't
win yeah
okay what about judo have you ever done
any judo
no never done
what about calisthenics
wow i love calisthenics yes
um
and and you know what it is
being able to lift weights is good but
being able to move your own body weight
this is the important thing because if
you can bench press 100 kilos but you
can't even do five pull-ups
what are you training for you know
because you need strength that can be
applied into real-life situations
um so yeah i'm very uh
i'm a big advocate of uh calisthenics
all right bro while we wrap it up do you
have any last questions for me
i don't think i've got any questions
i've got a few bits of
final points for the audience inshallah
go for it then now's the time
number one
if you know for the non-muslims if
you're
following any ideology
that doesn't provide proof for its
reality then you need to question it you
need to question why you believe what
you believe
because
one day you're gonna die and you don't
know where you're going and
it's very clear that there's more to
life than what we think that is
so
you know
find a an ideology the only ideology
that provides
untouchable proof for his reality and
that's islam so do your research and
don't assume that you've got time either
because we all think we've got time but
we don't we're going to die
and
yeah if anyone's got any
you know questions or want
some
you know they're interested in islam
then i'm always open for
for uh
questions inshallah and fired i'm sure
that's the same with you as well 100 100
100
so guys
if you made it this far i should say
this way
hit up instagram find the barnett vision
wonderful work that i'm seeing on his
page give it a follow support his work
insha'allah and we'll get to the last
questions and end the stream bro i look
forward to having you again inshallah
very soon
okay so next
uh
let's see okay
okay
let's see this
okay brother if someone is 30 pounds
overweight should that person lose it
first before starting boxing
no in my opinion though i think anyone
can start
stop boxing at any time boxing in you
know
it doesn't require you to be slim like
boxing is going to help you lose weight
so i
i think this is probably from shaytan
like just delaying your your your your
fitness journey for longer so start as
soon as possible insha'allah
writes how to adopt or adapt with
emotions of loneliness and voids when
you started
it's a good question but alhamdulillah
like i was never lonely because i had
amazing brothers around me from the
beginning so
i don't think that i'm the best person
to answer that
okay
next have you ever personally physically
been to speaker's corner because you
mentioned you watched the videos
yes i have yes i have and it's
it's a crazy place but there's some gems
there there's some there's definitely
some gems there um if you go on the
right day then
you know you can listen to some very
fruitful discussions
and may allah bless all the
uh
you know all the
debaters or you know not debaters but
people
guys like people who are
doing work for islam
i mean bro i mean and all the dua bro
not just the ones we see
but just the ones we also don't see bro
because how many of them are just
they're doing private dawah you know
they're doing the see how they're
they're doing the the bread and butter
but they're not just out here with the
followers and with the likes so may
allah keep us all steadfast and keep us
all humble and keep us all you know
grateful that allah guided us bro
because at the end of the day allah
didn't owe us anything bro
but allah saw something in us and and
saw potential and and decided to guide
us so
may allah allow us to never take that
for granted and and never test allah you
know
and just just keep passing all of
allah's tests that allah throws away
because at the end of the day that's all
we could do bro we're here for a limited
amount of time just like you said we
don't know when our time is going to
come to passing and all we could do is
live every day like it's our last and
for your fitness thing man if anyone has
any questions on boxing you want to take
your box into the next level go on
instagram check out the barnett vision
one word and inshaallah he'll take care
of you insha allah
foreign